The “Analyze Gene List” feature can be
used to investigate a list of protein or small
molecule identifiers with or without expression
data.
The tool performs over-representation and
pathway-topology analysis on the input data.
The submission process recognises many types
of identifiers.
As part of the pre-analysis, they are mapped
to Reactome molecules.
The ideal identifiers to use are UniProt IDs
for proteins, ChEBI IDs for small molecules,
and either HGNC gene symbols or Ensembl IDs
for DNA/RNA molecules, as these are our main
external reference sources for proteins and
small molecules.
There 2 types of data format that can be submitted.
To submit the qualitative data, the data should
be a single column of identifiers such as
UniProt IDs, gene symbols or ChEBI IDs.
They are matched to Reactome pathways and
tested for over-representation and pathway-topology.
To submit the quantitative data, the data
should have a column of identifiers as before
and one or more additional columns of numbers
such as expression or dose-response values.
This will be recognised as quantitative data
and an additional overlay process will be
run along with over-representation.
The numbers are used to produce a coloured
overlay for Reactome pathway diagrams.
Selecting the Continue button on the Analysis
submission form brings you to an options page.
Several popular proteomics tools generate
results that contain a mixture of human and
other species identifiers.
When the default option of Project to human
is selected, all non-human identifiers in
your query are converted to their human orthologous
equivalents.
As Reactome pathways represent human events,
this conversion will maximise the chances
of a successful match to a Reactome pathway.
However, you may want to uncheck this box
if your query represents data from an infected
tissue, i.e. it consists of a mixture of human
and microbial identifiers.
To prevent conversion of non-human identifiers
to human, uncheck the box.
The “Include Interactors” option is unchecked
by default.
With this option selected, Reactome pathways
are expanded by including all protein-protein
interactors from the IntAct database for every
protein represented by the pathway.
This can greatly increase the size of the
pathway and extend it to include proteins
that would not otherwise be represented, which
maximises the chances of matching your submitted
identifiers to the resulting expanded pathways.
However, the risk of this pathway expansion
is that the expanded protein set has not been
verified by manual curation and review.
You should understand that IntAct interactions
may be ‘false positives’ due to artefacts
resulting from the technology used with no
biological relevance.
For single-column input list of protein or
small molecule identifiers, over-representation
and pathway-topology analyses are performed.
The names of the columns are explained when
you hover over the column name on the Reactome
webpage.
Analysis results are shown in the Analysis
tab, within the Details panel.
All Reactome pathways are shown, in blocks
of 20 pathways, ordered by ascending false
discovery rate or FDR value obtained from
over-representation analysis.
In addition, the number of molecules matched
to total number of molecules and FDR values
are added to the right side of pathway names
in the Pathway hierarchy panel.
Reactions that contain any of the matching
molecules are boxed in orange.
When you click on the name of a pathway in
the Analysis tab, the Pathway hierarchy will
expand to show it and its name will be highlighted
in dark blue.
If it has sub-pathways, you can use the plus
buttons to the left of the pathway name to
reveal sub-pathways and reactions.
Analysis results can be filtered for various
factors, including pathway size, significance
threshold, p-value and species, using the
funnel shaped filter icon on the top right
corner of the Details panel.
By default, all molecules are used for over-representation
analysis.
Subtypes of molecule can be selected from
a drop-down list in the filter option.
Selecting these subsets will re-display results
that consider only the selected molecular
subtype.
Another option in the filter allows users
to ignore disease pathways for the analysis
as it might skew the results in some cases.
The Analysis tab in the Details panel has
three buttons on its left.
By default the Results button is selected.
Below this is the “Not found” button that
indicates the number of submitted identifiers
that were not successfully matched to molecules
in Reactome.
Click on the button to produce a list.
If a significant portion of the identifiers
could not be matched to pathways then ether
the identifiers are not compatible to use
with Reactome and you should replace them
with something more suitable, or the identifiers
represent molecules that are not found in
our pathways, but might be connected to a
known or unknown definable process.
Analysis results are also reflected in the
diagrams of pathways and reactions in the
Diagram panel above the Details panel.
Under the Network view, each pathway in the
network view of pathways is coloured in different
shades of yellow according to the over-representation
significance or p-value.
A selection bar at the bottom of the Diagram
panel will allow you to colour pathways based
on the coverage which reflect the number of
matched entities instead of p-value.
Under the Voronoi view, the voronoi map view
show the same information as in the network
view but this view is easier for users to
visualise the results.
Textbook-style diagrams represent analysis
results within the label for subpathways.
The label background changes from blue to
white, a yellow band is used to indicate the
proportion of the pathway that is represented
in the query dataset.
A grey bar above the label indicates the number
of pathway entities that is represented in
the query dataset, the total number of entities
in the pathway, and the FDR corrected probability
score.
Under the SBGN diagram, entities in the diagram
are coloured yellow if they were represented
in the submitted data set.
Complexes, sets and sub-pathway icons are
coloured to represent the proportion of the
molecules they contain that are represented
in the submitted identifier list.
To examine the details of a complex or set,
hover the mouse pointer over it, a small blue
triangle will appear on the right side.
Select this to open an information panel.
The uppermost tab on the left size will be
selected, the molecules represented by the
complex or set are displayed as a table, with
a yellow shaded background if they were in
the query dataset.
If you submit data in a format that includes
columns of numeric values, following a first
column of protein, compound or other suitable
identifiers such as probe IDs, the analysis
tool will interpret your data as expression
data.
The numeric values are used to colour objects
in pathway diagrams.
The results page is very similar to that of
a qualitative input analysis with single-column
list of identifiers, with additional columns
in the Analysis details.
These extra columns represent the submitted
expression values.
Clicking on a pathway name launches the relevant
pathway diagram.
Things to look for include:
• Objects in the Pathway diagram are coloured
according to the numeric values submitted.
The gradient yellow to blue colours are based
on a scale, which is represented in a bar
on the right hand side.
• When zoomed out, objects are coloured
to reflect the average of the values submitted
for the molecules.
When zoomed in, complexes and sets will resolve
to coloured bands, representing the values
of individual molecules.
• The experiment browser toolbar is used
to step through the columns of your data,
such time-points or disease progression.
As you move across the different columns,
the pathway diagrams will re-colour to reflect
the new values.